Alhamdulillah. Continuing
[Silence]
with the fourth invalidator of
for
[Silence]
So here the author takes us into the
first invalidator of wudoo that is
strongly debated amongst the scholars of
Phil
which is
that a person touch his
member
whilst on wulu.
And in order for us to understand the
difference of opinion,
we need to understand
exactly what is meant
by invalidating a person's wuboo with a
touch.
So,
[Silence]
And so what's intended here by the type
of touching that will break a person's
wool or is purported to break a person's
wool
is touching
the penis specifically
without
any barrier, some cloth or glove or
piece of clothing. So, it's skin on skin
contact directly and it is with the
inside of the hand, not the outside.
It's the inside of the hand. So, it's
the inside of the fingers
and the palm to the wrist.
This
is what is meant by touching
and it is intentional.
Person intends to touch
and this takes out a lot of
misconceptions with respect to this
because many people will hear
the narration of the prophet sallall.aii
Whoever touches his penis, then he is to
make woo. And they'll understand this to
mean if a person is drying off after
they get out of the shower and they act
inadvertently brush against themselves
or if a person has their clothing on
and so forth. And this all roots back to
two narrations.
These two narrations seemingly conflict
directly with each other.
And these narrations are highly debated.
Some scholars view both narrations as
inauthentic. And this is a very strong
opinion because both narrations have
weakness in them.
Others view v both narrations to be
authentic.
Others view one narration to be more
authentic than the other. Whilst others
view one narration to be authentic with
the other inauthentic.
If we were to choose, we have
along with the majority of the scholars
who
view that the strongest of the two
narrations. Now notice the wording here,
the strongest of the two. Does that mean
that either of them is authentic? this
statement, the strongest of the two.
Does that mean that one of them is
authentic? Not necessarily. It just
means compared to one another, one is
stronger than the other doesn't
necessarily mean either of them is
authentic. only in comparison to one
another. The strongest of the two is the
narration
of
whoever touches his penis then he is to
make this is the strongest of the two.
This is the opinion of
that this is the stronger of the two.
However, whether or not the narration is
even authentic at all is hotly debated.
Ali
views the exact opposite. Alim Ahmed
is with Albkari along with the majority
of scholars. However,
for our intents and purposes, let's
assume or let's say that we were to say
both of them are authentic, acceptable.
How would we how would we
harmonize between two narrations like
this? So, we've got one that says
a man asked the prophet sallall.aii.
He said
a man touches his private part
whilst he is in salah.
And the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
responds and says
meaning is that anything more than just
another part of your body?
The rhetoric here is that no this
doesn't break your woo. Then we have
another narration.
Whoever touches his penis then he has to
make woo.
If a person is in salah
are they going to be touching their
private part skin on skin? No. This
is highly unlikely. highly unlikely.
Second of all, even if they were, what
makes
the private part specifically of a man
his penis?
Because that's the exact wording of the
narration
which means the testicles or any other
part of the private parts does not break
your
according to the consensus of the
scholars.
What makes
that part of your body different than
your arm or your chest or your cheek or
your chin? What makes it different?
always its function.
[Arabic recitation]
that's a place of that can be
sexually
geared, right? Cuz it has more than one
function. It's either just another part
of your body or it is a very critical
part of the body when it comes to
sexual
you know sheha when it comes to
sexual intercourse and so forth. So this
is the only time that that part of your
body is different than the rest of the
parts of your body. The only time when
that part of your body is different than
any other part of your body is when it
is viewed or touched sexually.
And for this reason,
the best opinion is that
it is an invalidator of wool. If a
person intentionally touches skin on
skin, the penis specifically and for the
woman her front private part
with
arousal out of arousal. This is when it
invalidates a person's woo. If we were
to say it does,
why not? Because touching
in itself breaks a person's woo. Because
the breaking of wudoo is for what comes
out of the body. That's what really
breaks wudoo. Even deep sleep or
you know intoxication or
unconsciousness. Why does it break a
person's wuboo? Because it itself breaks
the wuboo or because of what could have
escaped the body during unconscious
state? The second. Right? So really the
essence of what breaks a person's woo is
what? What comes out of the private
parts what comes out of the body not
what touches interacts or goes into the
body.
And that is correct. And if we are to
look at that pattern and see it true,
then this is because touching the
private parts specifically in a sexual
manner, skin on skin is going to break
your woo or is going to likely break
your woo by something coming out of the
private parts. Which one is it? Likely.
Just sleep, right? Likely because
when a person has that and they have
reached to the point of touching then
now
this is what is called
meaning that pre-perm and these other
things start to come out of the body and
so it is likely strongly likely to
break.
The scholars of Islam, they have a
principle and they say Islamic law takes
that which is most likely or highly
likely and gives it the ruling of that
which is definite.
[Silence]
And so this is why sleeping deep sleep
breaks a person's woo based on this
right and we could give many examples of
this for instance Why does a traveler
shorten his prayers in essence?
Why why
I didn't ask what it is. What why is it
why do we have this?
[Arabic recitation]
Is every travel a difficulty? Every
single one?
No.
It is most likely going to be difficult
but not necessarily. Therefore,
right?
Likewise, sleep breaking a person's
wudoo. Does it definitely break your woo
or is it highly likely that your woo was
broken? Highly likely. And we know this
for a fact. Why? Because the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam
would often times wake up and not make
wudoo. Therefore, if deep sleep broke a
person's wudoo, he would make wudoo.
However, that's not what breaks a
person's woo. What breaks a person's woo
is
And we could go on and on and on. There
are many examples of this all through
the legislation. And so this is no
different.
If this were to be authentic and if the
narrations are authentic, what is
the best thing to do? The best thing to
do is that if a person touches directly
his penis or a woman her sexual parts,
then they are to make
[Arabic recitation]